I like you so much I wish you had landed
that punch on until we require I'm not
gonna lie and I mean and this is I had
oh I had a wonderful time on that movie
which meant Spiderman her mind anyway
Lois but spider-man and um there there
were there was like an electrician who
well there was a crew guy who came out
to me and said listen home I'll give you
$100 if you if you hit him in the face
by accident and well then you know and
he said me and some of the other guys
are in on it and I'm and I looked over
and like there was an electrician
plugging something in he just looked up
to me give me that look like question in
the face guys like Wow well now with the
Tobey Maguire you could have played
Seabiscuit I can't believe I didn't get
that call see us again
yeah now I'm gonna be resentful
Seabiscuit was offered a hundred dollars
to kick Tobey in the finnex 100 bales of
head 100 carats on the beach in slow
motion
[Music]